hello it's been a while since i've
talked about art on this channel so i
thought today let's both stay up all
night and think about one of the
paintings that puts me down this kind of
spiral of overthinking the in the best
way possible and um let's analyze one of
my favorite paintings shall charlie
the painting i want to talk about today
is the execution of lady jane gray and
apologies to all my french viewers but
um it's a painting by paul de la roche
and i really want to talk about today
because it is a painting that makes me
feel so
alive and
human because of how striking and strong
this painting is so if you've never seen
it before and you are in london or ever
plan on vegan london it is in the
national gallery it is one of the
paintings i tend to kind of bee line uh
just go straight for every time i go in
the gallery because it's absolutely one
of my favorites it is so so so so
incredible and i just want to break down
my own interpretation of it and why i
love it so much today before i get
started this painting on the surface
looks as though it's quite a sad and
depressing piece of art and although
definitely it has a lot of themes of
kind of despair and depression i think
in the end it is one of the most hopeful
and beautiful paintings that i've ever
seen and i'm kind of going to explain
why it makes me feel this way and the
kind of emotional journey that it takes
me on if that makes any sense to anyone
else what we see in this painting is the
moment right before the execution of
lady jane gray she is actually the a
real kind of historical character she
was 17 years old in this painting so she
was just a child and she is being
executed after being dethroned she has
been the shortest reigning monarch of um
england ever i think she was just on the
throne for something like eight or nine
days before she was executed and
beheaded and this moment kind of
captures the time of the execution um in
this painting just like uh to see who is
there so lady jane is the one who has
the white dress um and is in the center
of the painting and then we also have
kind of her ladies in waiting who are
against the wall um just in utter kind
of sadness and despair and then we also
have the executioner and i don't know
who this man is who is kind of like
hugging her and taking her to the
execution block but yeah he looks like a
priest or something like that but just
there's there's that man too um so yeah
these are all the characters in the
painting and obviously we can see in the
center lady jane is the center of
attention now looking at this for the
first time the first feeling that i get
is
about how ridiculous humanity is i think
this painting just highlights how stupid
our structures and the things that we
have in place are i think it is
literally a juxtaposition the fact that
we can have such you know beautifully
woven clothes and such beautiful
buildings in general and everyone is
just dressed so well and to have the
intelligence and the technology to
create these sort of things while at the
same time needlessly beheading a child
just makes everything just clash so much
in my mind and on my in my eyes and it
just gives me this strong feeling of
utter ridiculousness for humanity i
think it just shows that we fall into
these structures of society and roles
and um even kind of you know
there's a queen and an executioner and
just all these structures just come out
of necessity and are born and keep
things alive but i think it takes
moments like this where we are all
standing around waiting to behead an
innocent 17 year old girl that just
highlights that
this is not okay and it takes a moment
to realize that somewhere we did
something wrong and something needs to
change and i think this painting just
makes me very much feel that i want to
change something and i want to do
something because
things have gotten to a place where they
are utterly wrong i think there is a
deep sense of sadness in the way that
this lady is killed in the sense that
there is no aggression there is no kind
of anger or
accident it's just very cold-blooded and
calculated and just a thing that needs
to happen and the fact that it is all
being carried out so slowly and in such
a planned manner makes me feel as though
just someone here could have stopped and
said okay you know what she got the
point it's fine we can just stop we
don't need to go through with this thing
but the fact that they can do this with
such a cool head makes me kind of
shudder for the way that we can
sometimes act or the way that we can
behave in as humans in life there's such
a contrast between the ladies in waiting
and the men in this painting because the
ladies seemed
utterly shattered and in such despair
their behavior is very similar to the
kind of feeling i feel that anyone would
have looking at this painting
as in
why is this happening there's so much
pain in um that girl's face when you
look at it and on the other hand we have
the men and they are quite calm and
collected and especially the executioner
is has quite a interesting stance and
look on his face he seems so detached
from the situation as though he's just
you know waiting in line to get
a burger at his store and there's this
sense of almost curiosity in his face um
there's no pain or sadness and the man
who is guiding her towards the block i
feel as though his position is very very
interesting because he seems it seems as
though he's just you know guiding her to
bed after she had laser eye surgery he's
just so casual and almost comforting in
what he's doing in her last moments that
it is it's quite ridiculous everyone
seems to have accepted the situation but
are expressing their feelings around it
in different ways so the ladies are
utterly anguished but they're not doing
anything about it and the men are
completely detached and clinical about
what is about to happen i feel as though
lady jane becomes more relatable than
anyone else in this painting not only
because she's kind of the center of
attention but she seems so vulnerable in
this pose everyone else is so well
dressed and so put together there's not
a hair wrong these ladies in waiting
also have like proper hats on and all
their clothes are buttoned up but she is
quite vulnerable she's in her
undergarments her hair is messy so we
can relate to her even more because of
this kind of position that she is in in
the painting and it's also quite
shocking how rich everyone is and this
sadly makes me slightly even more
uncomfortable for what is going on i
feel as though if this was a peasant
girl who were being beheaded i would
have a different sort of reaction to it
i would perhaps be kind of angry at the
world but in this situation it brings
less than anger more despair because it
feels as though even people like her who
were a queen cannot escape the structure
that we've created so it is in a sense
so depressing to feel as though if she
can't
get out of this then who can how can we
how can we make things better it seems
to kind of no one can escape from the
sadness that is the structure of
humanity that we've created and the
richness just permeates everything you
can see the background is so clean and
beautiful the architecture is great
everyone is so well dressed they
literally have a velvet cushion on which
she is to kind of kneel when she's going
to be beheaded which is so ridiculous
because if we're gonna have to throw
that away um it's you know going to be
covered in blood or something so
everything seems so disposable and of
such a high quality that it just there's
this sense of
kind of
richness and comfort everywhere and this
sort of tragic brutal situation around
such
kind of money and riches makes it even
more uncomfortable for me for some
reason the thing that makes this
painting even more bizarre for me is how
calm everyone is um no one seems to be
fighting the situation everyone has
accepted their fate and this was quite
interesting in kind of the historical
records of lady jane ii she was a very
beautiful very well-educated very polite
and wonderful lady and it's actually
quite well known how she went to her
death so she didn't fight or kick or
scream she just put a cover around her
eyes and very politely asked to be
guided and towards the executioner's
blog and that was i think very rare and
interesting and no one here is fighting
against anything this whole passiveness
in the painting the lady who is to be
killed she's quite passive her ladies in
waiting they are kind of crying in a
corner but they're also passive they're
not shouting or screaming or trying to
stop anything there's no one else in
this painting i feel that for this
reason it becomes even more powerful
because it makes it kind of puts the
responsibility on me i am it's just me
and this painting and i am the only
person who can kind of scream out so it
kind of in my head raises this desire to
take action it kind of makes me feel as
though if i were there i would just
scream and say okay stop stop this is so
crazy can you not see how ridiculous
this is and i feel as though because
there's no outlet for me to take this it
just remains with me this desire to
cause a change this desire to pick out
ridiculous things and bring a stop to
them is kind of left with me after i see
this painting this is this kind of
energy that it leaves so every time i
see it it kind of leaves me thinking
what are the kind of rules and systems
that i'm accepting and adapting and
living by what are the sort of things
that i am doing one by one just like the
executioner just standing there and yep
this is how i react to this thing this
is how i feel about this certain thing
what are those parts of my brain and
behavior that i just
accept because they are systems there
but are actually just as ridiculous as
the execution of this girl are there
parts of my brain that are just as
anguished as her ladies in waiting
because of the things that i do but i'm
just shutting down and accepting anyway
and i feel as though this is the sort of
thought process that i want to go
through after i leave and because this
painting leaves you with so much pent-up
energy and so much kind of frustration i
want to take it out on seeing hey what
can i change about myself what can i
change about my thoughts and what can i
change about my life and this is not
actually only in a negative way but i
feel as though this painting just
highlights just how lucky i am about my
life how unlikely i am to be kind of
executed by the states for certain
things that i do even though i would be
innocent that is very unlikely to happen
i would say in this day and age that's
actually something that i should be so
grateful for because it really was not
that was not the case for the majority
of human history this painting also
gives me hope because it's captured such
an interesting moment um it's not as
though artists have shied away from
capturing very brutal scenes so they
could have captured the moment after her
execution or the moment where her head
was on the block but this is just one
step before that it's just one it it
just gives me enough time to feel as
though someone could have done something
and therefore someone should do
something and therefore that's the
energy that it leaves with me rather
than the thought of humanity is so sad
this is so hopeless even though i know
that in history that is what happened in
this in in real life in the painting
that thing still hasn't happened yet so
it leaves me with a sense of
appreciation that if this were to happen
today if this is my life then things can
end differently and i can still
implement those changes and still shift
things around and therefore this is why
this very depressing very sad tragic
event in history captured in this
incredible painting leaves me with a
sense of kind of positivity hope and
appreciation but also a very very
burning desire to take action and to do
something about my own brain my own life
and the way that i approach things in
general and i just want to say if you
haven't seen this painting before the
first time i saw it was not in real life
either it was um in a book probably
somewhere but this painting is huge it
is so so so so big in real life and i
think that just adds so much uh kind of
character to it and it feels as though
literally i am one of the people in this
room in this scenario you can lose
yourself in it and it's absolutely
incredible the the work of art is just
like nothing else the painting is so
well done the size of the painting is
huge and the quality and the setup of
everything is absolutely incredible so
being such a masterpiece it genuinely
has a very very strong impact and effect
on me and my life so yes every time i
get the chance to i absolutely love love
love love to see it so yes that was
everything i had to say about this
painting if you ever get the opportunity
to get a look at it in the national
gallery in london i would 100 recommend
it it's one of my favorites if you're
also like me going to be up tonight kind
of thinking about what you want to
change about your life and how to see
things differently you're welcome and
also apologies because yeah that's a
bittersweet thing so yeah if you did
make it so far thank you so much for
watching it was so much fun for me to go
back to paintings again because yeah
they're one of my favorite things to
talk about but um thank you for spending
this time with me i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day be kind
yourself and others and don't believe
everything you think thanks bye